et là comme depuis maintenant à peu près
2 ans qu'on a accès dans le grand public
à des outils comme chat GPT donc des
modèles de langage en fait on a des
robots des ordinateurs qui sont capables
eux-mêmes de créer d'analyser de
comprendre du texte c'est quelque chose
qui est vraiment une rupture et je enfin
dans l'histoire de l'informatique mais
plus largement je pense que dans
l'histoire de l'écrit en fait on n pas
eu beaucoup de révolution de cette
nature il y a eu bien sûr l'invention de
l'écriture elle-même l'invention de
l'imprimerie qui était décisive mais
ensuite j'ai j'ai du mal à identifier
quelque chose d'ussi euh singulier comme
changement euh technique que la capacité
d'une machine à écrire elle-même un
texte quand on lui demande quand on lui
donne le sujet et et la direction donc
c'est évidemment extrêmement important
parce qu'une grande partie de notre
société est fondée sur le texte euh à la
fois dans sa dans notre culture dans
notre économie et dans nos relations
politiques et effectivement comme vous
l'avez dit je suis en plus élu local et
donc je suis élu je suis adjoint au
maire dans les ivelines dans la ville du
PEC et et donc on voit aussi par ce
biaislà de quelle manière ça peut être
utilisé dans des cas d'usage très
concrets c'est le cas évidemment aussi
dans des entreprises avec lesquelles des
fois j'ai l'occasion de de discuter et
donc je pense que personne n'est
vraiment à l'écart de de cette
révolution